here's why I had your back on this
coronavirus nothing has really changed
it's still out there I see people in my
neighborhood walking around and they
don't feel they need to wear a mask let
me tell you this science it takes about
a thousand particles of virus for me to
spread it to you every time I speak or
breathe I breathe out 30 or 40 particles
if I'm positive
most of those particles hit the ground
from gravity if I wear a mask I can
block probably 90% of those particles so
if you do the math I have to speak to
you at a close distance for 10 hours for
me to spread the virus to you if I'm
wearing a mask
that's not gonna happen so you basically
can eliminate spread of the virus by
blocking particles wearing a mask and
then what friends say hey I'm having a
dinner party we're having 10 to 12
people we're gonna social distance how
can you social distance if you look
outdoors there's almost no spread of the
virus right you have a remarkable
ventilation outdoors if it's during the
day the UV light can degrade the virus
so the notion of getting a few couples
together outdoors sitting at tables that
are socially distance where the
waitstaff will wear masks I think is
very safe if someone said to you there's
gonna be a gathering of 10 people it's
gonna be socially dissing party you
would go to that why you know it depends
who the people are you know some of your
friends are going to parties with a
hundred people and you know other ones
your friends are acting like you you
want to be around people you trust their
risk tolerance and it fits your profile
would you take an uber right now I would
not I don't think the ventilation in
cars is good enough if you had somebody
come into your house to clean would you
trust that there need to be rules the
way we do it is there's a room and if
someone is going to clean that room we
don't go in that room for several hours
and we leave the windows open what about
a simple thing like a haircut if you did
it out of doors much safer going indoors
to a barbershop I would not do right now
you're a cancer specialist most of your
patients they need to go to the doctor
but you wouldn't go to the dermatologist
to get your each checkup
no I can delay that right all right I
mean to get a regular checkup with
Bloods and other things to make sure all
your medications are working that's a
very cogent thing the doctor is not
going to be on top of you listen we're
delaying cancer diagnosis
and a lot of people because they're not
going in with the small symptoms they
would have gone before we know the
earlier you diagnosed the better the
outcome the National Cancer to
estimating there could be tens of
thousands of deaths over the next decade
from people diagnosed later than they
would have pre kovat and that's not good
what about this second wave they're
talking about well first of all we have
to get rid of the first wave that's
right away we're still in a thousand
deaths a day that first wave is ongoing
at the present time right so anybody who
says there will be a second wave in the
fall has no idea what they're talking
about we cannot predict this virus it is
new we don't know its behavior and the
predictions in general are not accurate
I think dr. agus for coming on today and
here's what I got out of it and correct
me if I'm wrong I am going to wear my
mask I am gonna continue to social
distance spread the word to people don't
spread the virus spread the word to
people just put on your mask do me a
favor be a human being
let's do what our parents did in World
War two let's sacrifice for the good of
everyone it's not that big a sacrifice
to wear a mask I got it right dr. agus
yes and pray for science scientists and
we'll cross the globe many of them have
working 24/7 to develop treatments and
vaccines that we're all going to benefit
from and listen to the scientists